repeat them will be yahoo sports college
football writer odd he joins me here on
the show Pete we were speculating the
you left si because they wouldn't let
you work on si eats would you up can you
confirm I can neither confirm nor deny
that only if Sam's reports it John so
show this is Sean your colleagues right
there
new I'm new we coming at me we were
talking about the NFL teams that might
be tanking this year and all for the
purpose of drafting one of these top
quarterbacks you've written about these
quarterbacks how many let's say how many
top 20 guys how many top 20 quarterbacks
you think are gonna be in this year's
draft
I think they're tanking specifically for
talk radio show hosts like yourself
actually and throughout the Greater New
York market I think that's the actual
reason behind their tanking fascinating
concept right you have enough of it in
your in your day job covering the
covering the NBA I would say right now
Chris there are three quarterbacks who
you can say with some assurance will be
top 20 picks and then there's about a
field of six or seven guys who could
enter that with big seasons obviously
the the big three if you will are Josh
Allen at Wyoming Josh Rosen at UCLA and
Sam darn 'old at USC the suck for Sam
campaign has already begun in earnest in
in New York amongst the J et s fans
which is which has been fascinating and
then there's the second tier of really
good players the guy I like a lot is
Clayton Thorson at Northwestern a little
bit of a late bloomer coming out of high
school really started to find his own
last year played really well against
Ohio State how you play against those
one or two really high tier teams on
your schedule matters a lot to NFL
evaluators a I saw Mason Rudolph last
night from Oklahoma State I don't think
he's a first round type guy he's more of
a mid round type guy but he's guys gonna
be in the Heisman candidate Heisman
Trophy conversation for sure and then
the big dark horse named among scouting
circles right now is Tanner Lee at
Nebraska he's a Tulane transfer and a
lot of people thought he had some of the
best tools of all the quarterbacks at
the Manning Academy this summer how many
people drooling
/ josh allen have actually seen Josh
Allen play well he threw 15
interceptions last year I'm a little
pump the brakes on Josh Allen to be
completely honest with you I mean I know
some coaches out in that conference and
stuff and like I'm pump the brakes on
him as a top five pick we have to see a
lot more before that he is the physical
tools in its that the Carson Wentz
narrative which I think has drawn a lot
of people in Kris because he was
recruited by Craig Bohl and Brent vagin
at North Dakota State who recruited
Carson Wentz he was sort of an
overlooked guy and they have the same
build and they played in the same system
I just think that's a lot of
interceptions against bad competition
and Oregon goes there week three or four
this year that again this Oregon team
isn't the Chip Kelly era of Oregon but
that'll be an interesting test to see
him against a high end defense but you
know cement West coaches I know are kind
of like he could be a first-round pick
but I think for him to go number one
there's a there's a lot of runway there
he's got it he's got to prove a lot it's
not gonna be family senior writer Yahoo
Sports joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show Ohio State Pete last night
a little bit of a slow start against
Indiana for they stepped on the gas
anything you saw in that first half
against in the end of the troubled you
so I was in Stillwater last night Chris
at the Oklahoma State game so I was only
kind of peeking at my laptop to to watch
the Buckeyes that I mean look at the end
of the day like if you know they've won
by whatever 28 on the road in a
conference game against a bowl team you
know a reasonably good a reasonably good
team and that's about how they should
have done it I think there was some
adjustment to the to the new offense of
Kevin Wilson and Ryan Day when they you
know when when when things opened up and
I think the worry would be this they
still don't have an overwhelming
collection of skilled players that
receiver they're good but I'll Oklahoma
State has better skilled than than Ohio
State and that's that's one place where
that program has lagged the past couple
years and I think early on you saw that
you saw Harris Campbell drop drop Asher
touchdown pass he's his whole career has
been dropping passes and he's probably
the most talented guy so I think things
did click and sometimes a tempo and when
you're gonna run a little faster you
need some momentum and you need some
synchronicity and you need some cohesion
before things can get going and they
clearly did in the in the second half if
South Florida runs the table how high
can they climb in the rankings I think
they can get into the top ten easily I
don't know if they can get into the top
five or top what gets them into the top
five boy
they would have to really dominate
everyone they play I believe their only
power five-game this year's against
Illinois at home and it's not a Friday
night in September to me something
Illinois at home you know that's what
Ohio State Penn State Michigan are
supposed to do right like it we wouldn't
blink if they did that if that is the
highlight of your resume now I do think
that AAC is a decent conference Chris I
think it's it's proven the last three
four years under this configuration that
it can compete at a top 15 ish level in
college football but the problem is that
that league is gonna have the argument
against it is we can week out you're
just not playing these high caliber
seems right think about it we're
criticizing Ohio State for going to
Indiana when an Indiana caliber game is
going to be South Florida's best game
right think of anything that last
night's performance might work against
Ohio State more than it would for them
even though they won by 28 on the road
whereas their South Florida beats
Illinois by 28 that's gonna be their
their their landmark victories so I
think it helps that they've started in
the top 20 I think having Charlie Strong
there helps because there'll be a lot of
attention just like when Tom Herman was
at Houston like you need a you need a
guy who people are gonna want to pay
attention to and people you need to be
in the media's eye you need to be you
need to be in the voters eyes etc but I
just don't think at the end of the day
they could they could get there without
some kind of just perfect season you
know Quintin flowers would have to be a
top five Heisman guy they would have to
blow everyone in that league out of the
water but I'm skeptical that the
schedule would allow them to do that I
mean Houston had the perfect storm last
year because they had a bad high end
Louisville team and they obviously had
that home game against Oklahoma to open
the year where there were fourteen point
underdogs and just blew him off the
field we haven't seen a back-to-back
Heisman winner since Archie Manning
what nobody's really talking about Lamar
Jackson is being a front-runner why is
that
well our Pat 48 Yahoo Sports wrote a
nice profile of Lamar
this year I think he played terrible
down the stretch last year to be honest
that's probably the biggest reason why
we're not hiring well Lamar Jackson he
had a rancid offensive line that just
caused an all-out assault on him and it
didn't go well for Lamar at the end last
year he threw picks he looked disheveled
and I think some of it to Chris like
we're not talking about him because NFL
evaluators still aren't sure if he's
gonna be a quarterback or receiver at
the next level is he terrelle pryor or
is he Michael Vick we don't know I think
Lamar Jackson will be a high-end NFL
player of some caliber but is he Braxton
Miller I don't know so that's the
accuracy issues so the lack of NFL
conversation because he's not lumped
with those big three NFL guys I think
have led to the perceived nobody's
talking about that we're kind of at now
thank God we're playing games soon and
by the way I know Archie Miller by the
way not aren't you Manning my mistake on
that way before I let you go Pete I want
to get you thought on a college
basketball town or key grip Archie
Griffin why do I keep saying Archie
Miller I think I want to say Archie
Moore but he's the boxer right there's
like a handful of Archie's out there and
I can't get any of them right lamella
ball with this new sneaker line how how
much fire is he playing with when it
comes to eligibility with the NC
double-a he is juggling flames my friend
he is juggling flames here's the thing
about Lavar that you realized last year
if you around UCLA at all Lavar doesn't
care about NCAA Eligibility he would
rather get the pop of publicity that
comes with selling his shoes and the
controversy and being in the forefront
then he would actually like securing
eligibility for his son the Melo is not
as good as Lonzo right now yeah all
right yeah he's just not so look Lonzo
was better than his problems Chris does
that make sense yeah like he is a once a
generation type point guard maybe right
like he was a number two pick in the
draft
'la Melo is not that good he needs
college and he may need it for more than
a year like right now we're two years
out of projecting here but this isn't
some 7-foot to kid who we all knew at
age 11 was going to be a top five pick
so I just think
look levar what levar is done for the
most part has worked I don't know right
now on paper if this is gonna work it
could but I really think he put his
middle finger up to Indianapolis at MCA
headquarters with what he did yesterday
and it did not go unnoticed do you think
he's going to be eligible in a couple of
years
I mean NCAA Eligibility is like harder
to predict than like Powerball numbers
there's so much that goes into
amateurism and everything but I just
think the manner that this has been
handled chris is not going to help him
be eligible yeah I start going to the
d-league you'd know more about that than
me because the G excuse me the G League
I'm getting everything wrong yeah they
do they do when there's there's an
upside to that to some degree because
you're working with coaches and all that
but I thought you made the right point
in that lamella might not be good enough
to do one year in the G League and all
of a sudden gets drafted inside that top
ten he might need three years in college
or he might not be getting drafted at
all I mean he doesn't have the same he's
not as physically imposing as Lonzo is I
think Alonso's up a big strong point
guard initiative being a tall guy
lamellas skilled but I think there's a
real possibility he doesn't play at
least not high level basketball level of
Lonzo does and so going to the G League
wouldn't make any sense yes exactly I
mean those limitations and there's a few
right now the number one is physical now
that could change in the next two years
also Lanza was like a
once-in-a-generation passer I mean my
god what a gift he has to pass the
basketball I can't say right now that
lamella has that skill at that level
because I don't I've really seen any
point guards in college have it at the
level that Lanza has it for let's go the
best tailgate that you've been to in the
college ranks is where you know what I
do this is why you got fired from si
this is why you couldn't do si eats I
mean this is handle to eat I typically
like I typically like get to the game
three hours early and like walk through
with my eyes averted down because as you
know that you know the the liquid gold
temptations that that are that are out
in the parking lot I'm easily swayed by
Chris so I tend to I think this is my
best tailgate story I was
I was running once in LSU before an LSU
games like eight hours of for an LSU
game at night and a bunch of guys pulled
up in a pickup truck while I was like
sweating through my you know 2 and 1/2
mile saunter and like threw it through
me a beer
it's like LSU you're all right they
could clearly see I was just sweating
hey great stuff Pete great to busy
there's always meant I appreciate the
time thanks Chris
all right Spieth amyl senior Rider Yahoo
Sports joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience